Trascrizione: Jessica Venarotta
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Si può scoprire di più su una persona
in un'ora di gioco
che in un anno di conversazione.
Quelli che tra noi sono giocatori
sanno quanto sia facile,
quanto ci sia capitato spesso
il fatto di rivalutare una persona
da una partita, da una singola giocata,
anche se magari abbiamo a che fare
con quella persona, al di fuori del gioco,
da anni.
Questo adagio,
questo pezzo di sapere,
viene dato per antico,
viene attribuito a Platone.
In realtà, le prime tracce che abbiamo
sono di uno scritto del 1670,
in cui si invitano i giovani laureati
a fare attenzione a come una persona
reagisce alla vincita
o reagisce alla perdita.
Allora, cosa possiamo capire
da come una persona reagisce
alla vincita o alla perdita?
Ma mi spingo ancora oltre:
cosa possiamo capire
da come una persona
si approccia a prendere
quella strada che lo porterà,
inesorabilmente e inevitabilmente,
a uno di questi due esiti?
Io sono stato, per una dozzina d'anni,
un giocatore
di un gioco di carte piuttosto famoso,
si chiama "Magic: l'Adunanza".
Ho giocato parecchi tornei
con centinaia, con migliaia di persone.
Ho potuto osservare
molti giocatori, essendone uno.
Ci sono due cose che mi piacciono
particolarmente di questo gioco:
la sua grande profondità strategica,
e la possibilità, per i giocatori,
di agire al di fuori
delle meccaniche di gioco.
Ora, come funziona un torneo di Magic?
Funziona su una serie di match
in cui due giocatori si scontrano
e vince quello che per primo
vince due partite su tre.
Vince il match la persona
che vince due partite su tre.
Ora immaginate la persona
che vince la prima di queste partite.
In dodici anni
ho visto persone bullarsi
della vittoria, fare gli spacconi;
ho visto altre persone
congratularsi con l'avversario;
ho visto persone andare
in ansia da prestazione.
Prima ancora di pescare le carte
per la seconda partita,
questi comportamenti hanno un effetto:
qualcuno si intimorisce,
qualcuno si rilassa,
qualcuno si rilassa troppo,
qualcuno sopravvaluta,
qualcuno sottovaluta l'avversario,
qualcuno parte già
con l'idea che non ce la farà.
Allora, scegliere come comportarsi
ha un impatto immediato sulla partita,
un effetto immediato su quello
che sarà l'esito della partita.
Ora, la scelta di questo comportamento
o l'attitudine verso uno
di questi comportamenti,
ci dice molto di quella persona.
Ci dice se è una persona
che tende ad intimidire,
a non farsi scrupoli per intimidire,
ci dice se è una persona
che tende a mettere
a suo agio l'avversario
alla ricerca di uno scontro equo.
Ci dice se è una persona
che cerca, magari, di sfruttare
la zona di comfort dell'avversario
per fagli abbassare le difese.
Tutto questo non è altro
che come quella persona
si interfaccia con l'altro
nel momento in cui
ha qualcosa da guadagnare,
che è una situazione
che accade continuamente,
nella vita di tutti i giorni,
al di fuori del gioco.
Allora, come si pone
rispetto all'avversario?
Come se lo rappresenta mentalmente?
Come decide - anche
moralmente, ed eticamente -
di comportarsi?
Tutto questo apre una finestra
incredibilmente profonda
su chi è davvero quella persona.
Badate bene che non ho ancora parlato
di regole, meccaniche di gioco,
dinamiche di gioco.
Non ho parlato di nulla di tutto questo.
Siamo ancora al di fuori del gioco,
e già abbiamo incontrato
quello che è il primo
ingrediente fondamentale dei giochi,
che è l'Interazione.
Ora, io sono uno studioso della mente:
quindi entriamo pure nei dettagli,
entriamo in quello che è il gioco.
Il mio interesse è capire cosa succede
nella testa delle persone che giocano.
uno dei giochi che conosciamo meglio,
che abbiamo studiato di più, come umanità,
è il cosiddetto "Ultimatum Game".
L'Ultimatum Game
è un gioco ridotto all'osso
per studiare il comportamento
delle persone.
Funziona più o meno in questo modo.
Vi approccia una persona e vi dice:
"Mi hanno dato 100 euro.
li posso tenere solamente
se li posso dividere con un'altra persona
e questa persona accetta la mia offerta
al primo tentativo, senza mercanteggiare,
altrimenti questi 100 euro li brucio",
E procede a farvi un'offerta.
Allora, vi invito a pensare
qual è l'offerta minima che accettereste.
Chi di voi accetterebbe
un'offerta di 20 euro?
20 a voi, 80 all'offerente.
Chi di voi accetterebbe
un'offerta di 40?
40 euro a voi, 60 all'altro.
Chi non si accontenterebbe
di meno della metà?
Chi vorrebbe una parte
più alta della metà?
E ora, chi di voi
si accontenterebbe di un euro?
Bene, ok.
La soluzione razionale, a questo gioco,
è accettare qualsiasi cifra.
Pensatela in questa maniera:
siete stati coinvolti in qualcosa
che non vi aspettavate,
vi viene offerta una somma di denaro
e voi ve ne andate
con una somma di denaro in più,
rispetto a quella che pensavate di avere,
che sia un euro, che siano dieci,
20, 40, quello che vi è stato offerto.
Non potendo mercanteggiare,
avete solo la possibilità
di accettare o rifiutare.
Perché rifiutare, allora, un euro?
Rifiutereste un caffè gratis?
Probabilmente no!
Per cui, che senso ha
che rifiutiamo un caffè gratis, un euro?
Decenni di studi ci fanno vedere
che metà delle persone rifiutano
anche somme pari a 25 euro,
e il motivo pare essere
che riteniamo che l'offerta sia ingiusta.
In altre parole, stiamo dando un valore
al nostro potere di fare ottenere
del denaro all'altra persona, ok?
Questo che è un gioco molto,
molto semplice da risolvere in teoria,
ci pone davanti
a una questione interessante:
le persone pensano di agire
in un certo modo,
e si comportano diversamente.
C'è qualcosa di fondamentalmente
diverso nel giocare
rispetto al ragionare in astratto.
Le decisioni divengono atti;
un pensiero, un'idea,
un piano mentale diventa un'azione
e sappiamo ormai
che le persone non agiscono
come prevedono di agire,
che pensano di adottare dei comportamenti
e poi non li adottano.
Questo lo possiamo vedere
facilmente nei giochi di probabilità.
I giochi di probabilità non sono altro
che giochi in cui ci ritroviamo
davanti a situazioni come:
decidere se provare
a ottenere, ad esempio,
dieci punti con il 60 percento
di probabilità,
o 100 punti con l'un
percento di probabilità.
Quindi una somma bassa
con una buona probabilità,
o una somma alta
con un'infima probabilità di ottenerlo.
Magari sappiamo che ci conviene provare
per la piccola somma sicura,
piuttosto che per la grande vincita;
ma volete mettere il botto che facciamo
se vinciamo quei 100 punti?!
Ecco allora che siamo davanti
al secondo ingrediente fondamentale
dei giochi: la strategia.
La strategia è quell'insieme di scelte
che possiamo fare all'interno di un gioco.
C'è un'intera branca
dell'economia comportamentale
che guarda caso si chiama
"Game Theory", cioè Teoria dei Giochi,
che si occupa proprio
delle decisioni dei giocatori,
della struttura decisionale
all'interno di un gioco.
Io, da psicologo, sono
affascinato e interessato
alla nostra rappresentazione mentale
delle opzioni che abbiamo.
Quali sono i fattori
che ci rendono più appetibile
la grande vincita,
il miraggio della grande vincita
assolutamente improbabile,
rispetto a qualcosa
di molto più pragmatico,
molto più possibile da ottenere,
come una somma più piccola,
che potrebbe permetterci magari
di vincere con sicurezza,
o con una discreta sicurezza,
la partita?
Le persone hanno un piano
e poi deviano su una strada
che sembra più interessante,
che sembra più seducente -
magari più rischiosa, no?
Bene.
Allora intervengono, in questi casi,
quelli che vengono definiti
"bias cognitivi",
cioè dei problemi
della rappresentazione mentale;,
ma non solo, intervengono
anche fattori emotivi.
Emozioni: nell'Ultimatum game
abbiamo il senso di ingiustizia.
Nel gioco di probabilità
abbiamo l'attrattività seducente
di quella grande vincita.
Ora, l'evoluzione
ci ha dotato di strumenti
che non sono sempre così affidabili,
non sono sempre così razionali.
In un contesto naturale
potremmo trovare utile
sovrastimare delle basse probabilità.
Ad esempio, potrebbe essermi
conveniente pensare
che abbattere quel mammut
sia un po' meno difficile
se poi mangio io e mangia la mia tribù
per un mese intero.
Nel contesto odierno però,
siamo sommersi di decisioni continue
e spesso molto poco rilevanti,
come ad esempio:
che telefono comprare,
dove andare a cena stasera.
Ok?
E un accumularsi di un errore sistematico
può alla lunga produrre dei problemi:
insoddisfazione, frustrazione.
Ecco che, a questo punto,
il gioco diventa uno strumento
di auto-analisi eccellente.
Perché questo?
Perché nel gioco noi modellizziamo
il nostro comportamento.
Guardando a come noi stessi giochiamo,
capiamo quali sono
i nostri pattern di pensiero,
capiamo come sbagliamo
e capiamo quindi come nella vita reale
facciamo queste cose,
come nella vita reale applichiamo
schemi fissi ed errori conseguenti.
Immaginate questa analisi accompagnata
dagli strumenti della psicologia
e delle neuroscienze cognitive:
avremmo uno strumento potentissimo.
Ora, mancano due ingredienti del gioco,
che sono le regole e i premi.
Le regole, che devono essere
chiare ed esplicite,
ci permettono di descivere
ciò che può essere fatto
e ciò che non può essere fatto
all'interno del gioco.
In pratica, limitano
lo spazio d'azione dei giocatori.
Invece, con i premi
noi stiamo mettendo un obiettivo
che i giocatori
cercheranno di raggiungere.
Ora, la combinazione tra limitazione
e obiettivo da raggiungere
crea un'ambiente in cui
le persone giocano alla pari.
Cosa vuol dire giocare alla pari?
Vuol dire che in un'ambiente del genere
non importa più
come è andata la tua giornata,
non importa a che piano
sta il tuo ufficio,
non importa con chi hai litigato.
Tutto quello che accade nel gioco
rimane nel gioco.
Conta solo l'abilità
che il gioco richiede.
Allora un giocatore,
per quanto non competitivo,
cercherà sempre di vincere,
punterà sempre alla vittoria,
perché il gioco è fatto così, ok?
Allora, la struttura del gioco
porta i partecipanti a cercare di vincere.
È legittimo - e doveroso per tutti
i partecipanti - cercare di farlo.
Non importa se stiamo giocando
coi nostri figli o col nostro capo, ok?
Il gusto del gioco
potrebbe essere proprio questo:
giocare alla pari,
in un sistema di regole comune
in cui [non] conta
nient'altro che l'abilità.
Il vero motore dei giochi
si chiama: motivazione intrinseca.
È ciò che spinge a fare un'attività
per il piacere di farla.
Chi gioca, gioca perché gradisce il gioco.
Una persona che gioca,
gioca perché le piace giocare;
ma quando gioca ci mette tutta se stessa.
Il gioco è costruito su un equilibrio
tra sfida che pone al giocatore
e abilità del giocatore.
Un solutore bravo di sudoku
non cercherà sudoku semplici;
uno scacchista cercherà
avversari del suo livello,
una persona bloccata a un certo livello,
a un certo punteggio di un videogioco
ha raggiunto il suo
livello attuale di capacità.
L'impegno e lo sforzo mentale
sono portati al limite.
La cosa bella è che questo
risulta divertente alle persone.
Giocare è divertente.
Quindi cosa facciamo nei giochi?
Diamo il nostro meglio,
lo diamo per nostra stessa volontà
e ci divertiamo.
Ora, se noi ci aprissimo
ad una psicologia del gioco,
potremmo avere,
accanto alla "Game Theory"
una "Game Psychology"
che ci permetta non solo di analizzare
la struttura decisionale dei giochi,
ma anche di capire
come mettere le persone
nella condizione di dare il meglio
per loro stessa volontà, e divertendosi.
Allora immaginate
che possibilità immensa abbiamo.
Abbiamo la possibilità di rendere
ogni ambiente della vita
un 'ambiente in cui
le persone danno il meglio
per loro stessa volontà e divertendosi.
Cioè, rendiamo tutto un gioco.
Rendiamo l'istruzione un gioco:
i nostri figli cresceranno
automotivati ad imparare,
saranno curiosi, avidi di sapere.
Rendiamo la politica un gioco:
creiamo una struttura
per cui al governo ci vadano
persone dedite a fare il meglio
e che ci rimangano solo persone
che dimostrano di riuscire a farlo.
Rendiamo la salute un gioco:
creeremmo un sistema
per cui le persone saranno motivate
e si impegneranno a mangiare meglio,
ad adottare comportamenti virtuosi,
ad essere meno sedentari.
Rendiamo la conoscenza un gioco:
giochiamo, capiamo chi siamo,
capiamo chi abbiamo di fronte.
Grazie.
(Applausi)